come november joining us now is texas
congressman mike mccall who serves on
foreign affairs and homeland security
congressman maybe my civics is wrong and
i know you will correct me if it is
wrong but the democrats have the house
and the senate and the white house so
why do they need your help to fix the
immigration system
well they don't uh and you know that and
uh by the way happy easter uh trey and
uh
yeah i think uh look they they look this
this issue was fixed
uh in the prior administration i worked
with
president trump's team to get the
migrant protection protocols in place
remain in mexico and it worked and it
was stopping these uh you know if you
have a true political asylum legitimate
claim you can get in but about 85
percent as you know or not and they
while they remain in mexico it stopped
them from coming in
uh then you know once they get in it's
catch and release all over again and so
they rescinded these policies from day
one they own this and in terms of the
midterm elections they do own it they
can fix it but they don't want to
all right congressman you live in a
border state the great state of texas
for those of us who do not who don't
live with this on a daily basis
tell us how the border has deteriorated
in the last year and a half to two years
well you have uh you know almost uh
i don't know estimates of two to three
million that have come in under this
administration with title 42 is going to
be suspended in may they're projecting
500 000
illegals coming in in five weeks
uh you know trey you're a federal
prosecutor i was too you cannot sustain
this
uh and not to mention the fentanyl is
coming in we've seized
enough to kill the entire population
at the border seven times over with
fentanyl it's killing our kids you know
out there not to mention the the
you know the criminals coming in
and the human trafficking phenomena this
is probably the biggest human
trafficking event of our lifetime
and it didn't have to happen and that's
the saddest thing
about the whole situation
i'm in a border state
we have to absorb all this but i would
argue that every state is a border state
because they're not just staying in
texas they're moving on to other states
and every state in the country is going
to have to deal with this problem
all right
that's your homeland security assignment
i want to switch to foreign affairs the
war in eastern europe is creating a
generation of refugees they're they're
fleeing a genocide i want you to listen
to the president then i'm going to get
you to respond on the other side
none of it should hinge on whether a
dictator declares war and commits
genocide a half a world away
yes i call the genocide because it
become clear and clear
that putin is just trying to wipe out
the idea of even being able to pee in
ukrainian
what's your reaction to that congressman
i mean a lot of people have been calling
it a genocide pretty much since the war
began i mean it's good that the
president's using that word but
it's always been a genocide to some of
us
well of course i mean you know russia is
trying to exterminate the ukrainian
people
i think most telling our we had the
battle plans back last fall and the
intelligence showed as you were on the
intel and judiciary committee showed
that uh
hitting civilians was part of the plan
the battle plan from day one
and so we saw the bombing of the
maternal hospital and the woman who had
her baby
wheeled out and they unfortunately
didn't make it after that
the children that we could see from
aerial satellites being bombed by the
russians the bomb itself that went to
the train
station that had for the children on it
uh this is not only genocide but a war
crime and that's uh why my bill the the
war crimes bill passed the house for
going to the senate to call it what it
is and you know what you're in a federal
prosecutor you're like me we got to
gather the evidence of the war crimes
taking place right now and make sure
that this is taken to an international
tribunal where mr putin
and all of his cronies will be held
responsible all right i'm going to let
you go with this question congressman i
mean the ukrainians are doing a
phenomenal job playing defense but at
some point
there's there's a desire to play offense
is there any appetite that you can
detect
in the congress for sending offensive
weapons weapons that actually help
ukraine press the issue as opposed to
just playing defense
oh and the congress for sure
this is almost bipartisan in the
administration i i
pleaded with them last november i signed
off on all the foreign military weapons
sales they held them up last november
they had to wait till after an invasion
to make that happen uh now we're trying
to catch up when i was uh at the polish
ukrainian border several days ago uh the
one thing i saw that was very
encouraging uh trey were a lot of
unmarked 18 wheel trucks uh moving in
from poland into ukraine carrying a lot
of weapons but they need they need the
anti-aircraft they need the anti-ship
the idea that the ukrainians could down
uh one of the biggest warships that
russia has in the black sea i mean who
would have thought this
you know we were told to be over in four
days and now they could actually win
this war
if we would properly equip them i was
with secretary james baker last night
spoke at the
his institute at rice university and we
talked about what would reagan do
you know what and his response was well
you know what he would have done a lot
more and a lot sooner
i don't doubt it if anyone would know it
would be james baker congressman thank
you for joining us happy easter to you
and your family look forward to visiting
with you soon
you too trey happy easter
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else